this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business or just run a website
whatever it's Squarespace
check it out through the link in the
description below more on them in a bit
so nearly everyone has grown up hearing
the stories of the masked vigilante
named Zorro he's dressed in all black
and he fought with a sword to defeat his
enemies instead of having superpowers he
used his wits and his strength to take
down bad guys he took from the rich and
he gave to the poor just like Robin Hood
this is a fictional character of course
but Zorro was inspired by the real
Mexican American man named Joaquin
Murrieta on today's by graphics we're
going to uncover the life and the
legends of this bandit who became a hero
[Music]
before we get into the meat of wacky
Marietta's life story it helps to know a
bit of a backgrounds on the history of
California in the political situation at
the time it all started in 1542 this
this Spanish explorer named juan
Rodriguez Cabrillo who enter San Diego
Bay and dubs the new land Alta
California course the Native Americans
were already living on this land that
everyone was calling the new world and
the Spanish didn't bother to establish
their first permanent colony until 1769
and they called it San Diego the state
of California was split up into four
military districts or Presidio's group
of Spanish officers were then given huge
plots of land for their ranches these
were called the rancheros Mexico was
also occupied by the Spanish at that
time so hundreds of people walked from
Mexico City all the way to San Diego
California in order to work at these
ranchers from 1769 to 1833 a total of 21
Spanish missions were built to attempt
converting Native Americans to
Christianity as time went on more and
more Spanish settlements sprung up
around these missions and more
immigrants came from Mexico to establish
colonies in 1821 California gained their
independence from Spain as Mexican
territory but their victory it was
short-lived the mexican-american war
raged from 1846 to 1847 room of the
California was filled with gold and as
the new Victor's of this massive
Territory the Americans did not waste
any time making sure that they claimed
it all for themselves
[Music]
not much is known about the very early
life of Joaquin Murrieta aside from the
fact that he was baptized in a Catholic
Church in 1830 it is likely that he grew
up working with his family for one of
the rancheros but he was ambitious and
he wanted to become a rich man so when
he was just 18 years old he and as a
young wife they went to live on their
own in the mountains so that he could
search for gold this was years before
men were travelling around the world to
become a part of the California Gold
Rush he would have been one of the very
first Mexican men to discover the gold
he kept it quiet telling only his wife
and his brother about the discovery we
have no way of knowing how much money he
was making by prospecting gold but there
was rumor and speculation that spread
later on that some of the early miners
were finding upwards of $300 a day and
that's before modern inflation meant in
modern money well let's just say that
that a lot for him and his wife they
would have been very happy saving up as
much money as they could before starting
a family in 1848 the war was over in the
United States one the California
territory that same year gold was
discovered by a Swiss pioneer named John
Souter and thus the great California
Gold Rush began then traveled from all
over the world to try and make it rich
the American government they wanted more
people to settle in the new territory
and mind the gold so that they could
begin to revive the economy they didn't
waste any time at all letting people
know that there was gold in California
and even went to the extent of over
exaggerating how much men could
potentially make today we're still not
really sure how many people moved there
but estimates say that it was around 300
thousand immigrants from the United
States and Europe the only problem was
the Mexican men that of course been
mining the gold for decades before the
Americans got that one day hakin maria
turned his wife they were approached by
a group of american men they informed
him that mexico had lost the war and
they said that he had to give up his
gold mine he refused of course because
it was his home and that would be giving
up his family's entire future so these
men they grabbed Joaquin Marriott Ahrens
they tied him to a chair they forced him
to watch as they tortured and abused his
wife in front of him then they killed
her and they left marietta alone in his
grief this 18 year old boy was still
tied to the chair as these men galloped
away taking his entire life savings with
them eventually he managed to
do the knots from around his wrists and
he buried his wife within just a few
moments this group of men had taken
everything that he had worked so hard
for and there was nothing left
[Music]
heartbroken and traumatized teenage
Joaquin Marietta at no choice but to
return to his hometown empty-handed he
had expected to return to his family
triumphant in the riches that he had
found but now he had nothing left to his
name when he arrived he also saw that
his home village had transformed in a
short period of time American men were
now living there and the native Mexican
people that beat subservience in order
to avoid confrontation he soon learns
that he was not alone in the abuse that
he had endured after all this was the
Wild West and there were few options for
Mexican people to receive any kind of
help from law enforcement in the minds
of the Americans they were the victors
of the war and that gave them the right
to the lands even if excellent families
had been living there the rancheros and
missions for decades many of these
American men there were also veterans
and to some it didn't matter if these
Mexican people were civilians they
weren't still considered to be the enemy
Joaquin Murrieta knew that if he wanted
to survive he would need to integrate
into the new society that was being put
in front of him he began working as a
card dealer as a local saloon for the
Cowboys who were looking to play
blackjack and poker but even though he
tried to keep his head down he was still
constantly harassed by the white men
over the next two years the situation it
only grew worse for Mexican Americans
living in California after the
compromise of 1850 California was
bringing a lot of new money into the US
economy and its population it was large
enough to be officially declared a state
that same year California legislation
passed the foreign miners Act which
charged men $20 a month in taxes for
anyone who wanted to mine gold with
modern inflation this was more like
$1,000 a month and it made it far too
expensive for your average worker to
actually make a living
this causes gold miners to revolt and
many men became desperate for money and
there was a lot of tension in these
local communities more and more white
people began resorting to stealing from
the Mexicans in order to make ends meet
eventually the government could see that
their tax laws were only causing chaos
so they exempted all three white men
from being considered foreigners even if
they were European immigrants they also
reduced the tax from 20 dollars down to
a much more reasonable three dollars a
month indeed there were far more
entrepreneurs who were able to make a
fortune from selling products to gold
prospectors instead of having the
get-rich-quick mindset for example the
Levi's jean company began because the
founder Levi Strauss was able to sell
two prospectors who kept cutting holes
in their clothes of course the company
it still exists today and its value
that's about six point six billion
dollars many of the men who traveled for
the gold rush they died from disease or
they left penniless just like Levi
Strauss and his trousers entrepreneurs
or making much more money than the gold
prospectors Mexican business owners were
able to make lots of money from the
tourists who were coming through town
even though Hakeem Marietta had lost
everything he was still ambitious his
brother was also clever and business
savvy so he was able to earn enough
money to purchase a beautiful horse back
then having a high-quality horse was
like driving a luxury sports car it was
a sign of wealth and of status so when
the Americans noticed a Mexican riding
one they were incredibly jealous
especially since they were struggling to
make it rich in the gold rush they
couldn't believe that a Mexican man
could actually afford it so they accused
Hakeem's brother of being a horse thief
back then being a horse thief it was an
extremely serious crime punishable by
death
Joaquin Murrieta tried to defend his
brothers saying that he had purchased
the horse legally the men they chose to
punish him for just speaking up and
telling the truth they tied Maria her up
and whipped him bloody then the American
men they lynched Marietta's brother in
the town square even though he was
innocent of any crime now that the
second time the white men had killed
someone that Joaquin loved dearly at
this point the two closest people in his
life had been taken from him and it was
clear that even if he tried to work hard
and make a living through honest means
the extreme racism that now ruled over
California would continue to keep him
down and matter how hard he tried to
better himself
this young ambitious part of Joaquin
Murrieta it was now debt he had
transformed into someone who would
devote his life to revenge but rather
than devoting your life to revenge why
not set up a website for your personal
life or your business with Squarespace
and yes I'm aware that makes no sense
whatsoever but here we are and I'm gonna
tell you a bit about Squarespace before
we get into the next half of today's
video now sponsors like Squarespace
genuinely do you make what we do it
possible so you know if you've even
thought about getting a website you
thought hmm I sure would love a website
and I sure would love it if Simon and
crew got a kickback from that website
well this is the way you can make that
and capitalism I work people Squarespace
allows you to create a powerful online
identity for yourself your brand your
business and look I don't know who you
are I'm sure I would like to but you're
on the other side of this camera and you
know maybe you don't need a website but
look if you if you've got a business of
any variety if you're a person if you're
looking for a job right and if you go to
search your name into Google and there's
just that weird serial killer guy from a
hire that comes up because he shares
your name that's not a good thing
employers they want to be able to find
you and your profiles and a great way to
increase your presence online is with a
website so get a Squarespace website
make it for you if you're looking for a
job if you're like a professional and
you do stuff you need a website and you
can do that with Squarespace they make
it super easy
it all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content or you
can start from scratch or just easily
move it over from an existing domain I
don't even know how that works how to
start it from scratch although I use
template because my design skills are
pretty rubbish and once you've gone
through the super easy customization
process there's no updates there's no
patches there's no tech BS that you have
to deal with
no one likes tech me s and expressed
based angle all of that website e stuff
if you want to do a podcaster mailing as
social integrations it's all there and
much more 24/7 customer support as well
if you've ever got a question and
Squarespace isn't just about an online
presence you can totally sell stuff and
services on their sites as well look if
you're looking to start a business or
outrank that serial-killer
in google Squarespace is a great way to
do that head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to Squarespace com forward
slash biographic and save 10% off a
website or a domain and guys please do
use our link it really does make a
difference it means that we can keep
making these videos
I appreciate it the team appreciate it
and let's get back to it
[Music]
the day after his brothers lynchin
Joaquin Murrieta completely snapped he
felt that he had nothing left to lose
and he was ready to get revenge even if
it meant risking his own life
Rakeem waited until the middle of the
night and he kidnapped the man who was
responsible for his brother's death then
he murdered the man using a blade and
chopped up the body he left pieces lying
around the camp so that the American men
would find their friend in the morning
one of the men in the camp could hear
something going on so he walked outside
to see his friend's body parts scattered
around the camp here and catch the
killer the only lights it came from the
flames of the campfire and they spotted
Joaquin Murrieta they recognized him as
the young man that they had whipped
earlier that day and he was the brother
of the man who was killed he was dressed
in all black so it was difficult to see
in the darkness but they could see the
whites of his eyes they were filled with
rage before they could react Murrieta
was already riding away on a horse the
men shot after him but none of the
bullets came into contact with him
clearly the men must have missed but
according to their version of the story
it was as if cracking had some
superhuman quality about him that helped
him escape unscathed
the men they were terrified and they had
good reason to be every night another
one of them would be found dead with
their body parts scattered around the
camp even when they were on the lookout
for Murrieta he still somehow managed to
slip in and slaughter his next victim
word spread that there was a phantom
like bandit coming for a revenge on
behalf of the Mexican people at first
rocky Murrieta was only killing the
white men who were responsible for his
family but that was not enough for him
he began hearing stories from other
Mexican people who had been abused and
he decided to go after the men who were
the most violent rapists and murderers
he was passing judgments on them like
the grim reaper deciding when it was
time for them to die
Murrieta was serving vigilante justice
as he saw fit and he had no guilt or
remorse for doing so at this point
Joaquin Murrieta was technically just a
cold-blooded serial killer but the
Mexican people had been beaten down for
so long that everyone saw him as a hero
finally the white men were afraid of
being cruel to the Mexicans because they
were afraid of getting on Marietta's hit
list it did not take long for other
young people seeking revenge to step up
and offer helped Joaquin Murrieta a gang
of men and women they began to look up
to this man as their leader all of them
were in their 20s and 30s and they had
similar tragic backstories to Murrieta
the Americans had killed their family
taking their money and their homeland
for themselves since many of these young
people had lost their families they
decided to call themselves the Murray
ashes one of the most memorable members
of the gang was named Manuel Garcia but
everyone there called him three think
and Jack because well as you might
imagine he only had three fingers there
was also a 16 year old boy named preyas
Felice and his older sister their
parents had been killed and they had
nothing left to live for except revenge
Joaquin Murrieta fell off of Elise's
sister and they became lovers who were
both willing to avenge the families that
they had lost after a while the gang had
killed all of the men who were
responsible for ruining their lives but
they did not stop their life of crime
they became like a troupe of Robin
Hood's Merry Men the gang members would
travel through San Joaquin and
Sacramento Valley's list suing white men
they would steal their gold and take
their horses before riding off with
their treasure in their minds they were
really just taking back the gold that
had been taken from them in the first
place and rebelling against their
oppressors upon returning home to their
villages the gang was met with cheers
and people were finally able to rebuild
their lives after having everything
taken away from them however since they
were only killing when it was absolutely
necessary and left many of these men
alive had left plenty of witnesses who
were able to report the theft to the
authorities eventually they demanded
help from the California Rangers the
named Wild West is very fitting for good
reason in the new American territories
there were plenty of areas that were
totally lawless the California Rangers
were tasked with being the state's law
enforcement but they would only be sent
out on location for the most serious
cases once word spread that a Mexican
serial killer and his gang of bandits
were murdering white men around the gold
rush the governor of California offered
a $6,000 cash reward for Hokkien
Murrieta
he was now wanted dead or alive now
$6,000 might not sound like a ton of
money for a group of men to split over
killing a bad guy but keep in mind that
with inflation this is closer to about
two hundred thousand dollars to date
this was more than enough incentive for
the Rangers to assemble and try and find
him a man named Harry love was the head
of the California Rangers for several
weeks they tried and failed to find
Joaquin Murrieta this was especially
difficult considering that several other
Desperados were also named Joaquin
finally they kidnapped Joaquin Murrieta
brother-in-law and tortured him until he
gave up the location of
the gang was hiding in 1853 the
California Rangers rode out to the
location where the men had been spotted
and shot all eight members of the
Murrieta gang after examining the bodies
they saw the famous three fingered Jack
and this is how they confirmed that they
had in fact found the right group of
people the only problem was that no one
actually knew what Hakim Murrieta
actually looked like there were plenty
of illustrations of him circulating
abouts but they were all artistic
renderings of a maniacal looking Mexican
with crazy eyes
however hairy love claims that he was
confident that he could identify the
leader Hakim Murrieta
therefore he cut off the body's head
preserved it in a jar of liquor and
carried it home with him he then put the
head on display and charged people $1.00
per ticket to see it as morbid as it
sounds people came from all around to
stare at the head of the dead bandit who
had been terrorizing California just one
year later in 1854 a writer named John
Rowland Ridge published a book called
the life and adventures of Joaquin
Murrieta the celebrated California
bandit the author Ridge also went by the
name yellow bird because of his Cherokee
heritage it was important to him to
document the story of Joaquin Murrieta
from the perspective of the Mexican
American people because it was an
example of the atrocities that Native
people had to endure after the United
States occupied the California territory
without his book the true backstory may
have never been told and he would have
gone down in history is nothing but a
cold-blooded killer
the story of rocky of Murrieta has been
retold multiple times since then but
yellow Birds version is still considered
to be the most accurate portrayal
unfortunately this was not the ends of
the oppression against the Mexican
people in America though in 1855 the
greaser Act became law
back then Americans called Native
Americans Indians and Mexican people
were called greece's because of the
perception that they were dirty they
gave Americans the right to arrest
native people for being vagrants the
definition of a vagrant it was very
vague and it could just mean someone who
was considered loitering or traveling
from place to place this was meant to
cut down on gang activity by the Mexican
Desperados but it was also targeted at
forcing Native Americans to stay in
their reservations limiting their
ability to travel because of the greaser
law or any Mexican or Native American
man could be thrown in jail for 90 days
simply by standing around town or going
on a vacation this took away the ability
for anyone except white men to search
for gold in California and it limited
their opportunities for growth in the
local communities as the years went on
it's only gave
more and more power to the
anglo-american economy the story of
Murrieta vigilante justice was so
compelling that people began to tell it
over and over again throughout the West
in 1919 a writer named John McCauley
wrote a short story called the curse of
Capistrano this was based on the true
story of Joaquin Murrieta only he
changed the name of the main character
to Don Diego Vega the story was so
popular it was turned into a movie in
1920 as time went on The Legend of Zorro
transforms whenever people needed that
spark of inspiration in the 1930s people
were suffering through the Great
Depression and they blamed the 1% for
ruining their livelihoods people of all
races began to feel that they resonated
with the character of Zorro because they
wanted to believe that there could be
justice in the world through sorrow they
could live vicariously and see someone
who took from the rich and gave to the
poor by the 1950s the character was
still just as popular as ever and from
1957 to 1959 Walter Disney Pictures
aired the show
Zorro on TV then in 1998 the mask of
sorrow premiered starring Antonio
Banderas but the inspiration it didn't
stop there author Bob Kane credits The
Legend of Zorro for the inspiration for
the Batman comics and inigo montoya from
the Princess Bride shares some clear
influences as well and it all started
back with Joaquin Murrieta for a man who
inspired so much popular culture you
might be wondering is that a grave where
we can pay homage to this bandit hero
well it turns out that ever was one in
2005 a filmmaker named John J Valadez
went on a quest to find the head of
Joaquin Murrieta that Harry loved kept
on display after ten years of searching
Valadez believes that he truly did finds
the head of Joaquin Murrieta and he
filmed a documentary about his entire
journey on how he tracked it down in
2015 he finally gave the man a proper
burial
a hundred and sixty-two years after his
death even though haki Murrieta has
inspired so many people there are still
many American Historians who refused to
see him as a good guy they say that he
was nothing but a criminal and a bandit
who terrorized unsuspecting Americans
but in Mexican history it is clear that
Joaquin Murrieta is and always will be a
hero so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below do not
forget to subscribe
brand new videos four times a week also
when you're subscribing hit the
notification bar see actually do find
out when we put out a new video and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]